Pokemon go is taking over the world one
pokey stop at a time but what do Blue
Jays slugger jose bautista and his
teammates think of the catch em all
crazed no it's not strong as
non-existent I haven't played it zero to
none non-existent I don't know maybe in
the future of all right now having done
the hot new virtual reality app has
caused controversy since its inception
with musicians like Beyonce and Rihanna
slamming the use of it during their
concerts and it seems the sporting world
is divided as Bautista and his voice
sounding off on playing in the stand we
feed after the fans emotions we fear up
the fans cheering for us so we are
playing pokemon marry watching the game
then what are you really doing that it
doesn't bother me at all it doesn't it
you know interfere with my performance
so if they want to do it and they have
fun go ahead Toby as long as in the
stadium they show us love they show
support if they want to play a Pokemon
go especially in a sport like baseball
where there is some downtime feel free I
mean I don't know much about it but you
know if there's some rare Pokemon in the
stadium by all means catching